hey guys welcome to our angry barrels
making up
we're gonna show you guys all the tips
and tricks take a look and see what you
think
so yeah there's kind of there's kind of
a running joke going uh with niko's
phone because he has this old flip phone
when a new video of ours breaks a
million views we will both get an iphone
4. as of right now i'm stuck with my
crappy flip phone yep and that's kind of
where this whole thing stems from
let's talk about barrels so as you guys
can see this is a really cg heavy piece
uh pretty much everything we interact
with is fake sam's actually cg for the
entire piece so for the barrels
basically i took a pre-existing barrel
model that i had and re-textured it as
you can see here
and for the slingshot what i did is i
made a rough model i kind of smoothed
the edges a little bit and then i
brought it in the mud box to put the
final touches and texture it sam used a
tablet for sculpting the slingshot in
mudbox you guys might have also heard of
a program called zbrush which is
basically the same thing for the effect
of the slingshot firing what i did is i
built a rough model of the sling and
then i used a cloth simulation to drape
it and stretch it what it does is it
gives it that natural elasticity that
you kind of expect from the slingshot
it's much faster than animating it by
hand as well it looks better this is all
done with 3ds max just using the
built-in cloth physics that comes with
the program once i have the slingshot
modeled and animated we uh use boujou to
put it into the scene now we also we get
a lot of questions with people asking
how do you render out something to put
it on footage well the answer is
actually pretty simple basically you
just render it into a format that has
alpha channels alpha channels are
transparency it's computer lingo for
transparency so formats like png
tiff's
exr one key part to making the 3d
objects integrate well with the live
footage is uh by rendering it with three
layers the first being the actual object
sitting by itself nothing else no ground
the second is just the shadows that go
underneath it and yeah and the third is
the ambient occlusion pass that kind of
gives the contact shadows you need once
all three of those are in the scene it
gives you a very realistic looking
composite now for the building
um we only see two sides of the building
so i didn't put a whole lot of detail
into the other side this both saved me
time and also didn't make the physics
simulation as complicated now for the
building really is just a matter of
building one window one pillar one
wrench and then just duplicating it and
moving it across the entire building so
it looked correct now when it came time
to do the physics simulation i
pre-fractured the entire building using
rayfire with everything pre-fractured i
could then have a box activated which is
this big blue box you see here and the
barrels inside this box so as the box
gets into the building it activates all
the geometry the barrel is hitting
everything it's flying all over the
place and it's just physics galore and
then for the actual building collapsing
is essentially the same thing except i
also use the bomb modifier to blow it up
and these big boxes you see here
activate the geometry and have
everything else fall over at the end
after that it's just a matter of
rendering it out
and sticking it on the footage
also thanks to jimmy for being the man
behind the camera
you